5 25 on your Friday morning it is not
too late for any Elementary student in
Clark County to enter the Mojave Max
emergence contest
in the last week or so the desert
tortoise who lives at the Springs
Preserve has slept through a coyote
Powell by and a bunny hop Vibes
[Music]
yes the two-legged Max mascots got the
moves in a cool hip-hop music video
encouraging all of us to save the
tortoise but as long as the real max is
still snoozing youngsters and their
parents and teachers are encouraged to
stop by mojavemax.com to not only learn
why he's a better spring prognosticator
for the desert and that groundhog back
East but also to enter the contest to
guess the exact date and time that the
elementary students think Max wakes up
and thanks to the folks that get
Outdoors Nevada the bunch of cool prizes
including laptop computers from the
winning student in his or her teacher
also a field trip to the Springs
Preserve with a pizza party where they
get to meet the real live Mojave Max in
person
mojavemax.com hey we always want to know
what's cool at school if you got
something send us an email also you can
check us out on our website it is under
the Community tab of 8newsnow.com and
the email address cool at school at
8newsnow.com